[Music]
all right grayscale Investments
ratcheting up the pressure after its
legal Victory against the Securities and
Exchange Commission exactly one week ago
in a letter sent to the SEC yesterday
grayscale urged the regulatory body to
reconsider its application to turn its
Bitcoin trust into a spot ETF is a spot
Bitcoin ETF going to happen this year I
mean there's a Hunger Games going on
with a whole bunch of different fun
companies we may get some answers when
SEC chairman Gary Gensler testifies in
front of lawmakers next week but until
then here to break it all down and maybe
give us a sense of whether it could
happen as popliano Investments Anthony
pop pompliano in studio in a fox
business exclusive great to have you
here in person thanks so much for having
me finally you're not in a TV box hidden
away I'm glad you're here uh first of
all what do you make of grayscale's
latest win and then the letter that was
sent yesterday is the pile on really
happening yeah the great part about
America is when there's disagreements
between Market participants and
Regulators they go to court they lay out
their arguments these are high-priced
lawyers on both sides that do the best
they can to convince the judge who's
right and the judge came down and they
sided with grayscale in this situation
now what the SEC has to decide is are
they going to allow this conversion but
that's not the only part that they
actually have to evaluate they also have
to look at the fact that you have other
ETF applications that are out there and
so it's kind of this great race do we
get the gbtc conversion first or do we
get ETF applications I tend to think
that we don't want to have a financial
Market where Regulators are playing
referee in the sense of they get to
choose winners and losers instead what
we want is we want Regulators to create
Fair markets and so from my personal
perspective the best thing to do would
be just approve them all at once say
gbtc you can convert BlackRock Arc uh
the other filers everyone gets to go one
two three go whoever gets the assets
gets the assets because part of what
we've seen in Prior ETF applications
that have been approved whoever gets out
there first they get the assets yeah
Fidelity I mean what is more basic and
accepted in the world than Fidelity
they're applying Wisdom Tree bit wise of
course BlackRock which everybody got
geeked up about and that's when the
price of Bitcoin spiked back above 30
000. right now it's around twenty five
thousand and change why do you think
that is look Bitcoin is a macro asset
and what I think we're really watching
here is it's a highly illiquid asset so
about seventy percent of all Bitcoin
this in circulation is being held by
people who over the last year have not
sold right and the reason why that's so
important is the price has gone up it's
gone down it's gone back up they're not
selling and so ultimately what we're
watching is uh I think the same setup
that we saw in 2020 going into 2020
there was this kind of inverted yield
curve there were CEOs leaving their jobs
it looked like we were heading towards a
recessionary period covet happens and we
get tons of money printed but they
happen to coincide exactly with the uh
Bitcoin having when that occurred your
demand shock Supply shock price goes up
hundreds of percent I think that we're
watching that exact same thing play out
here ETF application will be the demand
shock the supply shock is coming with
the having and we should go up hundreds
of percent again this is a trillion plus
dollar market cap now investors are in
it they some like it and for the SEC to
dig in its heels at this point beyond
what their job is to do and that is
protect the investor starts to look a
little strange but there are some legal
Minds out there and I want your opinion
on this who actually are speculating
that simply to make their case against a
spot Bitcoin ETF that the SEC would
possibly roll back its green lighting of
the Bitcoin Futures opportunities that
they have already put out there can you
put the toothpaste back in the tube on
bitto and bitty I mean these these
Futures Trading operations that you
could actually participate in now he who
makes the rules can change the rules and
so they definitely could do it I don't
think it's likely though I do tend to
think that there's a lot of speculation
on this stuff I do believe we will get
ETF applications approved uh before the
end of this year we've got about 100
days or so left to go uh BlackRock
knocking at the door Fidelity Etc I
think really helps but another key piece
of this and I think people kind of are
so focused on the ETF application that
they're not looking at the macro impact
and one of the things that recently came
out is Bernstein came out with this
brand new kind of prediction that this
stable coin Market these are just
dollars on blockchain is going to be
about a three trillion dollar market cap
now the reason why that's important is
125 billion dollars today so they're
predicting just dollars alone will go
from 125 billion to 3 trillion if that
happens Bitcoin and the rest of the
cryptocurrency market will likely be 10
plus trillion dollars we're talking
about a market that maybe is just over a
trillion today so these are huge there
are some who remember what happened to
Tara and Luna and those were so-called
stable coins which fell they broke the
buck or whatever they fell below a
dollar so to just say these are simply a
dollar equals a coin correct is a little
so that's where that's where I think
really uh people have to pay attention
to what are the regulated ones right and
so what we're seeing now is we're seeing
a lot of people remember JP Morgan came
out with JPM coin a while ago and so
that was a American Bank and some of
them are backed by U.S treasuries
correct so that's fair enough I do want
to get you on coinbase it's up 119
percent year to date it's been an
absolute brilliant performer it's
getting a lot of love because it's sort
of the favored you know surveillance
sharing partner with many of these ETFs
that are filing to do a spot Bitcoin of
course they have to work with the NASDAQ
specifically but
um what do you make of bitcoin's
prospects here they're looking quite
stable to use the term state so we've
been an investor in coinbase for a long
time from the private markets all the
way through the IPO and one of the
things that that business has always
been able to hang its hat on is it was
the leader in the regulated market of
the American Financial system and so
when you wanted to look at Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies coinbase was that
regulated leader and I think they've
continued to hold that position now what
you're starting to see is not only are
they able to serve retail investors
right I think they've got 80 to 100
million users whatever the number is
today but now they're also in
introducing things like lending to
institutions and so creating more
financial services around these assets
and so ultimately it's a business that
if this industry works it appears
coinbase will be one of the big
infrastructure winners I think that's
why a lot of investors are attracted to
it pump it's good to see you in person
in a tie in a suit and the American flag
you served for six years in the Army are
thanks to you for your service and for
coming here to talk to our viewers I'm
happy to be here I appreciate the invite
we'll do it again soon anytime